so I've talked about the partial
derivative and how you compute it how
you interpret it in terms of graphs but
what I'd like to do here is give its
formal definition so it's the kind of
thing just to remind you that applies to
a function that has a multi variable
input so X Y and you know put I'll just
emphasize that it could actually be you
know a number of other inputs you could
have 100 inputs or something like that
and as with a lot of things here I think
it's helpful to take a look at the one
dimensional analogy and think about how
we define the derivative just the
ordinary derivative when you have a
function that's just one variable you
know this would be just something simple
f of X and you know if you're thinking
in the back of your mind that it's a
function like f of x equals x squared
and the way to think about the
definition of this is to just actually
spell out how we interpret this DF and
DX and then slowly start to tighten it
up into a formalization so you might be
thinking of the graph of this function
you know maybe it's some some kind of
curve and when you think of evaluating
it at some point you know let's say
you're evaluating it at a point a you're
imagining DX here as representing a
slight nudge just a slight nudge in the
input value so this is in the X
Direction got your x coordinate your
output f of X is what the y-axis
represents here and then you're thinking
of DF as being the resulting nudge here
the resulting change to the function so
when we formalize this we're going to be
thinking of a fraction that's going to
represent DX so DF over DX and I'll
leave myself some room you can probably
anticipate why if you know where this is
going and well instead of saying DX I'll
say H so instead of thinking you know DX
is that tiny nege you'll think H and I'm
not sure why H is used necessarily but
just having some kind of variable that
you think of as getting small maybe all
the other letters in the alphabet we're
taken and now when you actually say what
do we mean by the resulting change in F
we should be writing as well where does
it go after you nudge so when you take
you know from that input point plus that
nudge plus that little H what's the
difference between that and the original
function just or the original value of
the function at that point so this top
part is really what's represented
d/f you know this is this is what's
representing DF over here but you don't
do this for any actual value of H you
don't do it for any specific nudge the
whole point largely the whole point of
calculus is that you're considering the
limit as H goes to zero of this and this
is what this is what makes concrete the
idea of you know tiny little notch or a
tiny little resulting change it's not
that it's any specific one you're taking
the limit and you know you could get
into the formal definition of a limit
but it gives you room for rigor as soon
as you start writing something like this
now over in the multi variable world
very similar story we can pretty much do
the same thing and we're going to look
at our original fraction and just start
to formalize what we what we think of
each of these variables is representing
that that partial X still still it's
common to use the letter H just to
represent a tiny nudge in the X
direction and now if we think about what
is that what is that nudge and here let
me draw it out actually the way that I
kind of like to draw this out is you
think of your entire input space as you
know the XY plane if it was more
variables this would be a high
dimensional space and you're thinking of
some point you know maybe you're
thinking about as a B maybe I should
specify that actually we're you know
we're doing this at a specific point how
you define it we're doing this at a very
specific point a B and when you're
thinking of your tiny little change in X
you'd be thinking you know a tiny little
nudge in the X Direction tiny little
shift there and the entire function Maps
that input space whatever it is to the
real number line this is your this is
your output space and you're saying hey
how does that tiny nudge influence the
output I've drawn this diagram a lot I'm
just this loose sketch I think it's
actually pretty good model because once
we start thinking of higher dimensional
outputs or things like that it's pretty
flexible and you're thinking of this as
your partial f partial x sorry your
change in the X direction and this is
that resulting change for the function
but we go back up here and we say well
what does that mean right if H
represents that that tiny change to your
x value well then you have to evaluate
the function at at the point a but plus
plus that H and you're adding it to the
x value that first component just
because this is the partial derivative
with respect to X and the point B the
point B just remains unchanged right so
this is this is you evaluating it kind
of at the new point and you have to say
what's the difference between that and
the old evaluation where it's just at a
and B and that's it that's the formal
definition of your partial derivative
except oh I mean the most important part
right the most important part given that
this is calculus is that we're not doing
this for any specific value of H but
we're actually actually let me just move
this guy give a little bit of room here
yes but we're actually taking the limit
here limit as H goes to 0 and what this
means is you're not considering any
specific size of DX any specific size of
this really this is H you know
considering the notation up here but any
size for that partial X you're imagining
that nudged shrinking more and more and
more and the resulting change shrinks
more and more and more and you're
wondering what the ratio between them
approaches so that would be the partial
derivative with respect to X and just
for practice let's actually write out
what the partial derivative with respect
to Y would be so I'll get rid of some of
this one dimensional analogy stuff here
don't need that anymore and let's just
think about what the partial derivative
with respect to a different variable
would be so if we were doing it as
partial derivative of F with respect to
Y now we're nudging slightly in the
other direction right we're noting in
the Y direction and you'd be thinking
okay so we're still going to divide
something by that nudge and again I'm
just using the same variable maybe you
would be clearer to write something like
the change in Y or to go up here and
write something like you know the change
in X and people will do that but it's
less common I think people just kind of
want the standard go-to limiting
variable but this time when you're
considering what is what is the
resulting change oh and again I always I
always forget to write in we're
evaluating this at an at a specific
point at a specific point a B
and as a result maybe I'll give myself a
little bit more room here so we're
taking this whole thing divided by H but
what is the resulting change in F this
time you say F the new value is still
going to be at a but the change happens
for that second variable it's going to
be that be b plus h so you're adding
that nudge to the y-value and as before
you you subtract off you see the
difference between that and how you
evaluate it at the original point and
again the whole reason I move this over
and gave myself some room is because
we're taking the limit as this H goes to
zero and the way that you think about
this is very similar it's just that when
you change the input by adding H to the
y-value you're shifting it upwards so
again this is this is the partial
derivative the formal definition of the
partial derivative looks very similar to
the formal definition of the derivative
but I just I just always think about
this as spelling out what we mean by
partial Y and partial F and kind of
spelling out why it is that the Leibniz
came up with this notation in the first
place well I don't know if Leibniz came
up with the partials but the the DF DX
portion and this is good to keep in the
back of your mind especially as we
introduce new notions new types of
multivariable derivatives like the
directional derivative I think it helps
clarify what's really going on in
certain contexts great see you next
video